good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy tuesday
i am so excited to be back here in
studio from florida last week looking
sun-kissed as ever
and joined by my entire family not only
is the love of my life the apple of my
eye my son
is here just to bring his good vibes i'm
also being co-hosted
being joined being co-hosted no
joined i'm here joined by
the other love of my life apple of my
eye my husband ben hi ben how are you
i'm doing great how are you i'm good i'm
so excited that you're here thank you so
much for gracing us with your presence
again i'm excited that i'm here too i
know that the show is basically carried
on my back
and i've read the comments and it seems
as though you really enjoy when i'm on
so that's why i'm here also because uh
jackie's not here but
yes well and also i intended to do to do
three episodes with you last week
but we we ended up not doing a studio
episode on monday and then you came
tuesday and then taylor strecker was
available wednesday
so the people were promised three band
episodes and they only got one
so this is the second one and i might
make you do another one at the end of
the week if the toasters demand it
because yeah we can we can keep doing
more of them i think that
they enjoy them i enjoy them we can do
more of them
well we've you know a really interesting
group of stories today one because
literally nothing went on in the world
and the longer jackie's away the more
respect i have for her
choosing stories it it is so hard
especially when nothing goes on
i would say there are two days in a week
when there's a lot to report on always
on a monday
because you know there's three days that
we haven't done a show and then maybe
towards the end of the week like a
thursday or friday today i'm not gonna
lie they are dry
but i'm covering a lot of bases because
there's a lot of things you want to talk
about
um that i don't think we would normally
talk about like nfts and
some you know golden state warriors news
is it ever really dry
when when it's me and you not ain't baby
it's not dry no
and when theo's here i mean it's just
threesome
when theo's here it's wet ben
sorry don't ruin the episode we just we
just started okay
um how are you doing like since last
time we saw you any big updates in your
life
no everything's good went to florida
florida's just my god
sunny beautiful happy yeah everybody
there just seems very happy
great sushi oh that's so much great
sushi that's actually a really good
distinction
people there seem to be like very happy
and excited about the prospect of life
whereas i feel like in new york there's
definitely this like morose
vibe i think it's also just weather like
when it's really nice here
like they're they're on a beach i don't
know it's hard not to be happy it's just
different like it's
90 degrees everyone's golfing
restaurants clubs all that stuff is open
how can you not be happy
so i was documenting a little bit on my
instagram so i kind of wanted to update
the people
also if you didn't listen to yesterday's
episode the reason why jackie's not here
is because she decides to spend a few
more days at her wellness retreat
it's going very well she vlogs the first
week on our patreon and there's another
podcast episode from our patreon up
now so patreon.com morning toast and i
can attest
i saw jackie she was we were glowing she
she looked great she seemed incredibly
happy ran into her on the 10th tee
i was golfing and uh she looked
great that being said she was wearing a
sweatshirt it was 95 degrees that's cool
sweatshirt 95 degrees wait i was going
to say something
before i went on my tangent it'll come
back to you
no fine go no i can't remember it i was
just gonna like steer the ship but it
sounds like you have something to say
no i was just gonna continue steering
the way that i was staring but you can
stare no no i'm the steerer
you're you're the star okay steer um
okay well not like the pressure's on
um i was gonna say
whatever okay so oh my god
have you ever done this have you ever
done this show before
you know the thing is is that the role
that i'm playing today is usually jackie
and i'm you so like jackie tells me what
to do
so like sorry what i was saying was that
there's a
ton of new content on our patreon
patreon.com morning chest and i'm very
excited to have you
and i'm very excited to hear your
thoughts on the goings-on of the world
great
do you think it's time to dive into the
past five i think that we should dive
into the past five because it seems like
we don't know what else to talk about
well we were on like a good conversation
and then i literally forgot what we were
talking about you know that's totally
fine so maybe we'll
do that we'll do the fast five we'll go
on a couple of tangents yeah i think we
can move on though like i don't think
you should like
okay we get it like i messed up that
never happens and you like can't get
over it
but i think we should move on is that
okay yeah we can we can move on okay
let's move on to the facified story is
that you no that's not how it goes
no it goes and without further i bet and
seriously
please shut up are you are you done
without further do here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast ben
seriously stop i have a job to do
is this show a joke to you no
today's episode is brought to you by
bruce the greatest electric toothbrush
on the market i have one ben has one
theo basically has one
why don't you have one bruce is the most
in my opinion the best most efficient
electric toothbrush
and the most affordable because a lot of
them cost over 200 which is just insane
they do yeah holy [ __ ] um the bruce
itself has six unique modes to customize
your brushing experience
comes with a magnetic charging stand a
compact travel case
and the charger the a full charge will
last you four weeks
so if you're going on a trip you don't
need to bring a charger which is really
great but the charger is very elegant
it's very tesla like very clean
i don't like a lot of clutter on my um
as you probably know from living with me
i don't like a lot of clutter
no you don't they also offer a
subscription program so you never forget
to change your brush head again
they'll ship you new replacement heads
every six months so you're never stuck
using a worn down brush head
their design is very sleek they have a
modern aesthetically pleasing design
and it comes in a bunch of different
trend driven seasonal colors so it looks
great on anyone's bathroom counter
get fifteen percent off your booth two
through bruce toothbrush kit and refill
plan when you use the promo code toast
at bruce.com that's 15 off using promo
code toast at bruce.com
all right first story we didn't really
talk about it because jackie and i
decided um about a month ago that we
weren't going to even like acknowledge
the oscars
and we didn't like i never saw any of
the movies except for promising young
women and i don't even think it won
which you saw too we watched it together
that was nominated yeah
what world do we live in where that
movie that was a great movie it was fine
that was like an indie film where are
there no big glitzy films
there's no movie theaters yeah i guess
so what a rough year um
oh it did win okay good i i loved for
screenplay uh oh yes i did see that
i loved that movie so no it was a very
good movie i'm just saying that's not
like when i think oscars
that's like seems like a nice low budget
film
okay i mean it was on amazon prime it
wasn't low budget but c was amazon prime
it wasn't like a big studio movie well
we're living in an agent
we're living in an age now where like
netflix they get nominated for oscars
yeah i saw that the exact same way that
i feel about the kids ruining the music
industry from last time
you think amazon and netflix are ruining
the movie industry why are you yelling
because i'm angry no seriously i calm
down okay but they're just like churning
out content because they know that they
can make money
they can get the subscription service
they can get the eyeballs but they make
great the content
is suffering why because they make some
good movies but they don't make
enough good movies well they make
content for everyone and not everyone
wants to watch
oscar-worthy movies for the most part i
hate watching serious movies like
netflix caters to me in other ways
that's fine but they're taking away the
opportunities for those oscar movies to
be made
because they're snatching up all the
talent so adam sandler
no shush for one second because you're
making no [ __ ] sense
so how are they taking opportunities
away from oscar movies
because they're taking the talent and
signing them to these
massive deals so you're mad that netflix
is taking money from rich hollywood
studios
no i'm just saying who's suffering here
i i don't follow your logic at all
who's suffering here the people that
enjoy good movies
why because there's even more platforms
for for people who want good movies
to get access to them i simply disagree
you're making no sense just admit that
admit it i think at one point i was
making sense but you've yelled me into
not making sense
just because you yell at me that i'm not
making any sense you're just like really
on one today like i need you to calm
down oh my god
i fully matched your energy that's all i
didn't even get to the headline yet okay
because you're going on some tangent
about hollywood studios
the oscar viewership has dropped to
record lows
because there's no movies makes perfect
sense who's gonna watch the oscars when
there are no movies okay if you
don't let me talk like and i know what
that sounds like coming from me okay
thank you last year's viewership reached
23.6 million view
viewers which was already an all-time
low this year
10 million wow they dropped by over 50
wow
so it was a steep decline in viewership
the 93rd annual academy
awards were watched by 9.85 million
viewers that accounts for a 60
58.3 drop losing 13.75 million viewers
from last year's numbers and last year's
numbers were already low
was it remote or were people in person
it was like a very small cocktail party
so it was in person there was a red
carpet everyone was sitting in the same
room
but i don't even feel like of course
award shows and we've been reporting on
every award shows numbers they're all
down
not by this much but also their record
low numbers are still higher than like
the grammys and the emmys
so the thing is and this is just my
opinion
i think of all the award shows for some
reason the oscars rubbed me the wrong
way
in the sense of like read the room it's
just like
the oscars are for me like you know very
snotty
very like celebrity very very out of
touch
almost all the time especially after
coming off of this year
when like people have gone through so
much i just like can't explain how much
like i don't need to hear
francis mcdormand like how well at the
moon do you know what i mean
that's my opinion as to why the numbers
are so down obviously other
circumstances too
like you know every year you know less
and less people have cable and this year
in particular like people are just like
they don't care but i think it's more of
like a
a read the room situation like the
oscars normally feel so out of touch to
me and this year it's like are you
serious
i think it's also just like what the
what what like what are we watching and
yeah a lot of fine movie but i thought
it was just like uh what are the movies
that you like with uh
oh i don't remember her name she goes to
she gets accepted to college
she has that boyfriend to all the boys i
love before
yeah like that's a rom-com this was a
serious i get it but i thought were you
even paying attention
yes i guess that i just thought that was
on a similar level in terms of because
it was on a streaming service yeah maybe
i mean i think also the fact that movie
theaters have been closed down for over
a year definitely had something to do
with the fact
of like nobody care caring about the
oscars yeah it's
a combination of movies i think it's
also a combination of or lack thereof
movies
uh lack of movies uh and the
declining cable as you mentioned i think
it's a huge thing too like i wonder
if they made it a little bit more
accessible if it was like on
made for social in some way yeah i
wonder if those numbers
okay so that's interesting like take
into account the amount of people that
like
so you think that like streaming
services are ruining the movie industry
but that they should also help the
oscars with their viewership
i think that streaming services are
ruining
the movie industry repeat your
convoluted statement that i disagree
with already no no i'm i'm just pointing
out a contradiction you just it's not a
contradiction
so you agree that you just said before
that streaming services are ruining the
music industry i mean the movie industry
streaming services are ruining the movie
industry yes
you said that you stand by that
statement i do you also just said that
like
social media and these new platforms
should help make the oscars
more accessible because people don't
have cable anymore do you not see how
that's a contradiction no there's a huge
difference between
cable and streaming services how
what do you mean they're two completely
different things no but you're not gonna
launch a streaming service from your
phone you're not saying the oscars
should be more accessible and you but
then you were clowning
on netflix i didn't i didn't making
movies more accessible
i did not use the word accessible once i
said that if they wanted to get their
viewership
up they should be where the eyeballs are
i'm really feeling like jackie today
just like pointing out
inconsistencies but you're they're not
valid inconsistencies i got you just
like
i i would take the l not it's not a
valid inconsistency
it's very very valid no it's not um the
eyeballs are on social
so that's where you want to be for sure
but the eyeballs are also on netflix and
hulu
who wouldn't want to be there no of
course they would want to be there
then make better movies i just feel like
we're in a really like i don't know if
people are following like what we're
saying we're like in a really nice
argument right now
um but all in all the oscars were down
58.3 percent
and i feel like they deserved it and i
don't feel bad for anyone involved
sure whatever that worked for you yeah
bad movies why am i gonna watch
something about bad movies with no stars
was leonardo dicaprio in a movie i don't
think so
you said you didn't see it in the movies
how do you know if they're bad
because none of that inconsistency that
was a good one that's true
no but i saw that one movie that's true
um next
up that was the movie from page six andy
cohen reveals the biggest topics covered
at the kardashians
reunion taping so i know you know that
the kardashians
show on e keeping up with the
kardashians is in its final season yes
they're going to hulu they're going to
make another show but this specific show
that we all grew up watching is kaput
and andy cohen you know from bravo he
hosts reunions for all of his shows
he's hosting andy cohen from bravo you
don't have to treat me like a [ __ ]
okay he is hosting a reunion
for the kardashians like a 20-year
in the making they cover everything so
he it's already been filmed
yes andy cohen revealed that courtney
kim chloe kendall
kylie chris and scott so there's no rob
and no caitlyn
didn't hold anything back when he sat
down with the family to keep to film the
keeping up with the kardashians reunion
special
here's what he said i will say that by
the end of the day i do not think there
was a topic that we did not cover
kim and chloe specifically were like we
want to do this we want to do this right
we want to go out with a bang we want
this we want to go here do your thing do
your thing
so wait so
but this is a typo on page six it was
intimidating when he sat down with them
because they were so not used to it
and he thinks that chris is very
conscious very consciously didn't want
to do this special
um because you know she's like the
she's in charge always but you sit down
in front of andy and you tell him
you know ask us whatever you want and
he's in charge so he got the vibe that
chris like wasn't
you know wasn't feeling thrilled about
it so here's what they got into
discussing
kim's robbery in paris which i've heard
her speak on a few times
the david letterman interview and on the
show
caitlyn jenner's transition kim's
marriage and ongoing divorce from kanye
west
chloe's divorce from lamar and the
cheating scandals with tristan thompson
that's what annie cohen said but the
most jaw-dropping moments for fans may
be when chris finally addresses whether
or not she set
up the infamous sex tape with kim and
ray j before the keeping up at the
kardashian premiere
right now this is what andy said i think
as it went on they all really started
leaning into it
and kendall at the end said wow this was
so great we actually talked about so
much stuff
we never talk about and we've never been
able to put to bed or a dress
and we did it and we actually did it
chloe is a big bravo fan and kim is just
so smart he said
and by the way i fell in love with the
whole family and the way that i think
everyone who watches the show
ultimately winds up falling in love with
them i really fell in love i think
they're really impressive only two of
them went to college
cohen revealed that he was set to host
the keeping up with the kardashians
reunion earlier this month on twitter
so this is obviously good press for
keeping up with the kardashians and it's
made to make you want to watch the
special and it's working because this
sounds so good
yeah but like you can also already tell
that like they're not gonna
divulge anything that is like too juicy
there's
a zero percent chance that kris jenner
goes on that show and says that she
set up the sex tape right he's sick but
there have long been rumors that that is
exactly like how their
entire career got started so the fact
whether or not she'll ever admit to it
the fact that like that rumor made its
way to chris
jenner and she's addressing it like
that's crazy and that's really only
something andy cohen could do
and that is why he is who he is and
that's why even after all this time like
no bravo no uh reality show reunions
can compare to bravo's like this is what
he does it's his bread and butter
that's how he got started really getting
on tv by hosting the reunions and
everyone was like
who's this weird like you know guy and
he's just
so natural at it and i actually cannot
wait for this special i think it's going
to be
so good and me and jackie spoke about
this the last season of keeping up with
the kardashians some of the episodes
have been
painful like so scripted they've
no one even wants to film anymore it's
just like painful to get through but
andy is all about the substance and i
think we'll get a lot of good substance
from this special
i reunion episodes are always
interesting i agree
um and the kardashians in particular are
interesting i mean even their worst
episode is better than
most half of the real housewives trash
in my opinion i
completely disagree okay that's fine but
even their worst episode is that
they're going to i'm saying something
even their worst episode is better
than wasn't i saying something first no
no i was
you coming roll the tapes i was just
gonna say even their worst episode is
better than like the best episode of
another shitty family tv show like every
family thinks that they're
so great for their own reality show and
most of them sting so
there's something to be said about being
on the air for 20 seasons that's what i
said
i said even their worst real housewives
don't clown on real housewives real
housewives is quality content
some of it is real housewives keeps the
lights on in here some of it is
i would say most of it every franchise
has a bad season now and then but it's
don't use that as in your example
interesting i'm just saying some
real housewives franchises are better
than others
obviously um but all in all will you be
tuning in
sure well i'll be tuning in so therefore
you will be tuning in
i said sure no i didn't say no
what is with you get off my ass today
you said
will you be tuning in seriously just
take a minute you are like really coming
for me today
chill you said will you be tuning in i
said did you hear what i said
i said chill that means you don't finish
your stupid point okay
next up oh next up is brought to you
next up is brought to you by relief band
ben seriously some of us are trying to
work here some of us take this job
seriously my god
did you know that one out of three
americans regularly suffer from nausea
we've all experienced that horrible
feeling whether it's in the backseat of
a car staring at your phone
after one too many on a night out with
friends or even just the anxiety of a
workday
nausea can ruin a day force us to change
our plans and in the most severe cases
make us unable to function for those of
you who can relate we've got good news
you've got to check out relief ban the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband
that has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve
and effectively prevent nausea and
vomiting associated with motion sickness
anxiety migraines hangovers morning
sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy and
provides all-natural relief with zero
side effects for as long as needed
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients
but now through relief brand it is
available to the masses basically relief
band stimulates a nerve in the wrist
that travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you that
you're sick
relief ben is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that has been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics
to treat nausea and vomiting and if you
know someone who deals with nausea
relief band makes a great
gift so personally i know jackie really
struggles with nausea because she gets
very car and seasick and i always get
nauseous when i'm hungover and honestly
the relief band is truly magical
can bring you peace of mind like if you
know you're going on a long car ride or
you're going on a boat and you might get
seasick it's just something great you
can throw in your purse and it's really
really effective
and as the world opens back up don't let
the fear of nausea keeping you on the
sidelines
right now relief ban has an exclusive
offer just for the morning toast
listeners
if you go to reliefband.com and use the
promo code toast
you can get 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions asked
30-day money-back guarantee so head to
relief band
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-e b-a-n-d
dot com and use the promo code toast for
20 off plus free shipping
relief band r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com promo code toast
third story of the day that sounds like
a wonderful product i just have to say
by the way i have one at home you can
use it i need it so
from new york post you saw um that elon
musk is hosting snl this week
oh so his snl hosting gig is causing
some outrage amongst the snl cast
giggles turned to groans for some
members of the snl ensemble saturday
when nbc announced that elon musk 49
will helm their sketch comedy show as a
host alongside musical guest miley cyrus
the contentious tesla ceo i don't even
know who's contentious
will be the first non-actor or
non-athlete to host snl since donald
trump in 2015.
elon musk tauntingly confirmed his
upcoming gig
tweeting out let's find out just how
live saturday night live
really is um he punctuated his cryptic
post with a little purple devil emoji
um but saturday night live quipster bow
and yang you know bonyang
yup he's honestly one of my favorites
he's great seemed to have hoped that
musk's social media memo was nothing
more than a joke
so yang questioned in an instagram story
he attached a screenshot of elon's tweet
and said what the [ __ ] does this even
mean
then edie bryant echoed yang's concerns
and posted a bernie sanders tweet about
um
how like the 50 wealthiest people in
america today own more wealth
than the bottom half of all the people
so and then she added a little
uh message let me repeat that because it
is almost too absurd to believe the 50
wealthiest people in this country own
more
wealth than 165 million americans that
is moral obscenity the cyber barb
continued
so then um a writer uh from snl
andrew dismukes joined in and said the
only ceo i want to sketch with is
cher e.o terry i don't care what that
joke is but
maybe some other people do so it
people online were like all for clamped
that it was him but
now snl cast members which like i don't
think i've ever seen
them like you're like that's like the
company you work for like you're
supposed to like you know i've never
seen them
even comment on the the selections of
hosts
and at the end of the day like elon musk
is one of the biggest
celebrities tycoons whatever you want to
call them in the world
so this is good for the show yeah
do you want to dive in first no go so
that i don't say something that maybe
elon musk is a [ __ ] legend totally
what's the problem
i don't understand like why is there
always a problem no it's not even that
it's like
they're the cast is so stupid first of
all let this be known
i hate snl i've loved snl for the
longest time
it's not funny anymore nine times out of
ten snl is not funny
the skits are bad covet snl is he's
horrendous
we don't talk about that because that
was so dark like it was right i prefer
to watch
give me the will ferrell snl skits on
repeat every saturday night
give me old like literally anything like
i just
old episodes like i'd prefer that over
any of this trash
that let that be known first and when
there is a good episode
there's always something dragging it
down there's always a problem it doesn't
know
elon musk hypes things up on social for
a living
in addition to being the smartest man
of our generation albert einstein of our
generation visionary
you see what he does with dogecoin he
goes on he hypes it up he says doge's
going to the moon
it's just press everybody buys doge he
uses his social
to drive press so he probably was just
driving viewership for snl
i didn't think there was anything wrong
with it let's let's see how live it
really is like
he all that he did there was get more
people to go and watch snl so do you
think that
the cast members had a problem with him
being selected or his tweet because
i don't think there was anything wrong
it's so that 80 bryant
has a 80 had a problem with him has a
problem with him and by the way i think
she's very funny
and i do agree with amy bright like that
is a crazy statistic
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
him can i yeah it is a crazy statistic
like 50
people own more wealth than 165 million
people like 100
like that is crazy and that's so [ __ ]
up
but like elon musk built a company like
that
it's not it's we live in a capitalist
like that's just is what it is so like
why so we shouldn't host snl because
he's too rich i just don't understand
take it up with the government it's a
big problem
elon musk it's not his fault he's
playing the game
that we allow him to play change the
rules
he can't be pissed at the player that's
a great
analogy it's crazy yeah change the rules
i agree it's [ __ ] up
there should be there should be a better
distribution of wealth especially
considering
the amount of people that are struggling
and living in poverty right now it
you can't hold elon musk accountability
it is especially wait it's not elon's
fault
no especially because i have to assume
that the guy does donate a significant
amount of money
no you have to assume someone i have to
assume yeah
but yeah no i mean i really hope he does
me too let's talk about that
elon if you're watching by the way
speaking of elon have you spoken about
the time
we met elon musk it's in my book go to
amazon and search girl with no job book
it's called girl no job the crazy
beautiful life of an instagram their
sponsor i don't want to spoil it here
for anyone who hasn't read the book yet
got it so buy the book and you can learn
about that story should we talk about
how me and elon are really friends
huh do you remember that he followed me
on instagram for a long period of time
what did he unfollow you no he deleted
his instagram
so i'm sure that when he reactivates it
i'm still somebody that he follows
yes he follows me oh my god that's so
exciting
we basically are brothers yeah pretty
much yeah
we're brothers are you gonna leave me
for him no
okay cool i would let you that's the
thing no but i would maybe i like i'd
leave you for the day
to like go hang out with him oh but not
romantically i no we're brothers
sometimes brothers kiss oh gosh um
well i'm excited i will be watching and
i hope
that you know it's not gonna be awkward
when elon shows up you know you think
he's already here
where do you think he's stayed should we
go to his hotel he's everywhere elon is
everywhere
yeah he's all powerful did you see all
knowing
like kylie and chris and kim took his
like underground yeah i saw that that
looks really creepy basically
he his company like they built this like
underground tunnel from la to vegas and
you can get to vegas in like an hour or
something yeah and it's basically just
like one long coffin and i was watching
kylie's stories and i was literally
gonna vomit like
what if you have to pee first of all
second of all like what if you change
your mind like
how do you turn around it was just like
this long like mri machine
so to the how do you change your mind
you can't change your mind when you're
on a plane
so i don't really understand that call i
guess you get on a plane yeah you're
going when you get there
you're there something about it just
looked like such a confined space it
looked
super claustrophobic so what needs to
happen it reminded me of like
lost like when they get in like that
little submarine and they go back to the
mainland
take some get a relief band or get like
uh you know like
take some valium or like yeah i guess
you need something it would just scare
me like
i don't know no for me i would need i
would need some drugs
yeah right it's like an mri yeah it's
like an mri yeah but that's fine like
yeah just give me a little something um
next story is a little more kardashian
news
kanye west's yeezy's just sold for a
record breaking 1.8 million dollars
so kanye west's nike air yeezy samples
have sold for 1.8 million dollars in a
private sale
making them the most expensive sneakers
in the world the shoes blew past their
original valuation of a million dollars
and fetched the highest publicly
recorded price for any pair of sneakers
confirmed by sotheby's auction house in
a statement on monday
the american rapper premiered the yeezy
prototypes in 2008
at the 50th annual grammy award grammy
awards although the style never
officially hit the
the shelves today sotheby's confirmed
they are the first recorded sneakers to
sell over a million dollars oh my god
cnn how repetitive are you so are they
the
first recorded pair over a million
dollars a million yeah
and they sold for 1.8 billion are you
saying billion
million wait oh
the single shoe a pair of shoes okay you
said
billion earlier and i was thinking that
you were talking about the brand
you're saying a single pair of shoes
just to recap your story
i'm sorry did i say billion yes i don't
think so
okay so yes so a sample from a 2008
collection that never made that never
hit the shelves
has sold for 1.8 million dollars got it
and they were west's very own pair that
he wore to the grammys they're a size
12. it was a quad they were acquired by
rares
which is an investing platform that
allows users to buy and trade
shares in limited edition and highly
sought after sneakers
the ceo and co-founder of rare's jerome
sapp
said in a press statement that
purchasing the grammy worn pair was akin
to buying a piece of history
he continued that our goal was a goal in
purchasing such an iconic shoe was to
increase
accessibility and empower the
communities that birthed sneaker culture
with the tools to gain financial freedom
through rares
i mean and then the sotheby's head of
streetwear said that the sale speaks
volumes of kanye's legacy as one of the
most influential clothing and sneaker
designers of our time
which i do agree with cool
crazy yeah i mean supply and demand man
supply and demand one of one what is the
most amount of money you've ever paid
for a pair of sneakers
those louis vuitton ones recently a
thousand bucks
hmm crazy that was too much
and was a birthday present from you so i
really didn't know yeah so
sorry let's just take a step back
because i got those for you so
you asked no i said what is the most
amount of money you that was a gift
you can't take my gift and make it your
thing
got it so actually i literally knew you
were gonna say that so
actually you bought me something
and then i returned it and used it to
buy the sneakers so again
who paid for it you did but who bought
them
me me not really you were just the one
at the store you bought the
air pods and you were the one at the
store because you wouldn't let me come
to the store with you
that's not true so now back to my
original question
what's the most amount of money you've
ever spent on a pair of sneakers i know
you love like common projects you have
like some cool basketball spaces
yeah you're not like a crazy sneaker
head no i mean the idea of owning a
piece of a sneaker
is the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] i've ever
heard in my life that's what that
trading platform is
you own a share a platform that bought
the stinky yes you own a share of kanye
west's sneaker
it's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
you can't wear them you can't put them
on your shelf
it's it's it's insane well that is dumb
but i did like what the guy said
oh my gosh the point of rares is to
increase accessibility and empower the
communities that birthed stinker culture
with the tools to gain financial freedom
yeah i mean that's cool so if that works
yeah it's also a really really good way
to
for the for the platform to look good
and the platform to make money
ripping off people in their houses i
mean that is a fair statement as well
great so now you get
three million people each giving a
dollar to own a piece of kanye west
sneaker
well this is also just great press for
this platform i hadn't even heard of it
what i'm saying like they're positioning
it as financial freedom for the people
that birthed kanye but really they're
just
kanye whatever having them each buy uh a
thread of his shoe
for two times the amount of money that
they paid so now all of a sudden kanye
west sneakers worth 3.6 million
when they only paid 1.8 yeah but then
the people who bought shares make money
too it sounds like it works for everyone
i don't think so because it increases
the value and they bought a thread for a
dollar now the threat is three dollars
i'm not entirely sure how it works but
it sounds like a good system okay like
its own little
economy essentially i don't like it okay
well uh speaking of things i don't like
we have one more story about basketball
but they actually relate perfectly nfts
are very similar to what we're just
talking about okay great we're going to
get into the nft discussion
in a minute because the nfts are brought
to you by noon
it's not okay so noom we know you guys
know we talk about a lot of
a lot of the time and when it comes to
losing weight and getting healthy
there's a lot of contradictory
information out there
things like the old-fashioned food
pyramid are not much help
so why noon it's not about what you ate
it's about how you eat in general noon
will teach you about eating your
cravings and how to build new habits so
you can ditch your misconceptions and
get smart about food and the choices you
make
numa is based in psychology so they'll
teach you how to eat you can accomplish
your personal health goals and stick
with them long term
because you don't need rules to lead to
lose weight you need
knowledge with noob you pick health
goals that are right for you some people
want to lose weight some people want to
feel better some people just want to
you know start watching what they what
they eat so you get a really
personalized weight loss program from
neum
to help your aspirations become reality
so
you either want to eat better you want
to feel better you want to you know feel
better mentally there's a million
reasons why you could want to get
healthy
nume will teach you why you make the
choices that you do and give you the
tools to replace your habits with better
ones
uh they're forgiving you're human if you
go off track you can be back on track
tomorrow jackie's been on the noon
program for a really long time i know
she really likes their food database
it's
one of the biggest and most accurate in
the world um and it's really
helpful when just trying to keep track
of where you're at throughout the day
um over 80 percent of numerous finish
the program and over sixty percent have
stuck with their goals for at least one
year
there is a science to getting healthier
and it's called new sign up for your
trial today at noom.com
toast n-o-o-m
dot com toast learn how to eat again
with noob sign up for your trial today
at noom.com
toast and if you're ready to live
healthier n-o-o-m.com
toast all right the golden state
warriors become the first professional
team to launch
nft collections the golden state
warriors launched a non-fungible token
oh is that what it stands for
on the open c platform tuesday morning
becoming the first professional sports
team to do so
this is the wave of the future of the
president branch schneider said
so we've been studying with the best way
for us to get involved and create
something for our fans is
nfts have been around for years but
they've really become more mainstream
and popular this year
the inflection point for us was to
really watch was
the inflection point for us was really
just watching nba top shots start to
explode
okay so honestly this these words i can
explain mean nothing to me yeah
okay uh nba top shot
took basketball cards and turned them
into
nfts nft is what an nft
is a whether it's a static it could be
an image
it could be a video it could be a
highlight but it's something
that replaces a spell card
a basketball card a piece of art so it
allows you to live digitally it's a
digital
collector collector's card correct but
it's only one of one even though it's
digital and i can take a screenshot of
it well it could be one of one
it could be one of sixty it could be one
of two hundred
they assign value and you have to buy
them but you can also just screenshot it
so that's where i don't
understand correct it doesn't make sense
to me
uh for most things uh
for basketball cards it's starting to
make a little bit more sense to me
because when you own a lot of basketball
cards you're not really displaying them
anyway they're probably sitting
in a binder in a box or in a binder in a
sock drawer anyway
so what's really the difference between
it sitting in there and sitting on your
phone
but for things like art i can't possibly
wrap my head around why
you would want to spend millions of
dollars to not have the piece of art
hanging on your wall
unless you're not collecting art to
collect art you're collecting art
because
art is a currency and there's a market
saying that this art is worth something
so cool
if you are simply going into nft art
collecting because you want to make
money
then of course supply demand makes sense
but if you're actually
trying to accrue art because you enjoy
it in your home
then this just doesn't make any sense to
me like i honestly like i still don't
get it
which part like the whole thing yeah
it's it's confusing
where what website do you buy you have
to download an app how do you buy
like get involved for nba top shop like
for anything well for the nba it's nba
top shot it's run by the nba
in coordination with this company i'm
forgetting the name of the company
and what they do is they release like
highlights from the vault
of footage that they have so for example
so youtube basically
yeah yeah basically like there's that
that's the thing it's like
there's nothing on an nft that i just
can't google
and find or screenshot like i don't
understand i go to the website
and it's like bid on this nft and
they're showing me a picture of it i'm
like can i just screenshot that and edit
to my camera roll yeah but i guess
that's sort of the equivalent like you
can just go and take a picture of a
lebron james rookie card and keep it on
your phone
no that's not the same because the
lebron james rookie card
is a tangible thing you can have it
me having the nft either via screenshot
or via purchase i still have it
digitally
okay so then it's the equivalent of you
can have a fake louis vuitton purse
yes it's not the real one
that is the correct analogy okay you
want the real one
look a lot of people don't okay so then
for the ones that don't this won't ever
appeal to them
i think that in general when people are
talking about this most most nfts that
are created and most that are in the
market
will fail like they're gonna go to zero
people are paid for nothing and it's a
massive ponzi scheme
but there will be a portion of them that
will always hold value and it's just a
good investment there's just like a lot
of things going on right now that i
personally do not understand like have
you heard of bid cloud
it's a new social media platform we're
basically like oh i saw this
your yes your fame or your followers
equals like your value in the market and
like literally somebody [ __ ]
took my book cover and made themselves
like a profile as me and like started
trading like they're up to like 30
already like it's so janky like all this
stuff going on like i i actually don't
understand it and like i'm starting to
feel old whereas like i'm
you know a tick tocker like i i get the
younger generation i do not get this
stuff like
i don't think this is the younger
generation i think that this is like
nerdy older generation
they have to stop it's taking advantage
of younger generations
and their money i can't [ __ ] keep up
big cloud i saw that i'm barely hanging
on with
doge let's check my doge i should have
sold it at 0.4 like everyone else
0.27 [ __ ] you still did pretty good
yeah look i mean i put in 200 and now i
have 1074.
i was at the casino i'd be very happy
but i'm just gonna hang on you know
maybe one day
like it'll go to you know ten dollars
that we how much would i make if it went
to ten dollars
a lot well please like go to ten dollars
that'd be so sickening
a lot so there's just like a lot in the
world going on that like i just refuse
to kind of understand and i feel like i
have a very high threshold like
i you know invested in tick tock like i
want to know what what the world is up
to
bit clout bitcoin you invest in tick
tock oh you mean like
my time and energy got it okay very
different oh i guess
no like i invest my time to like be a
well learned i am a pop culture
connoisseur it is my job to know what's
going on in the world but they are
making it so hard
no it's it's something nfts it's
something that i read the other day that
i thought was very interesting that is
very much in line with this we've become
a culture that is just so obsessed with
making money off of absolutely
everything that you do that you can't
possibly enjoy
anything anymore so when something like
this is presented
it's like oh [ __ ] i can make money off
this nft i can make money off having
this piece of art
i can make money off of bitcloud and new
social you're right it has nothing to do
with the art
and that's the by the way it all goes
back to it they're ruining the art
industry
it's the same thing they're ruining it
that was hysterical but it's true every
industry
every single thing i watch what industry
in your opinion is safe
i don't know hmm i don't know it's all
[ __ ]
um what was i saying no i was making a
really good point the art industry it
all comes back
no there was more for the sake of oh i
saw this tick tock the other day
it's like used to be a guy goes and
bakes banana bread or a girl goes and
bakes banana bread because she likes
baking banana bread
you can bake banana bread because you
like it without launching a banana bread
business
that is so true that is so true you have
to sell your banana bread you can do
because you like banana bread
your friends like your banana bread your
mom likes your banana bread no you're
right by the way we live in this like
hustle culture that's what yeah where
you have to
monetize every aspect of your life and
you can just enjoy things
without it and this is the exact culture
that it breeds where it's like now i'm
going to everybody's like oh nft nft nfc
doesn't
go straight right like they're quick
money we live in this culture
of like people just being upset like a
rise and grind get up monday motivation
we gotta hustle today that's a lot of
hustle
and it's like just go to work and relax
like we are in this like money obsessed
or don't try or don't go to work and
relax do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do
just be happy so i think the name of
today's episode is going to be something
about how all the industries are dying
they're dead the industries are dead no
no
and snl is dead too we've got art we've
got music
we've got movies and we've got snl and
the only thing that's not dead
musk he's going to no it's not dead tech
right and that's why elon musk has more
money than 165 million
a million people it by the way
i'd say that he said that he was amongst
the 50 the 12th
50 wealthiest yeah he's like in the top
like three yeah i would say that
he he deserves to be there
and we should just remove the other 49.
why you don't even know yeah but he's a
genius
he knew he really is that damn guy
builds rockets no and you're totally
right about like what you said is so
true like
that statistic is mind-blowing but it's
really not elon musk's fault and like
hating the rule like we live in a
country where it's like the american
dream it's so hard to get there
and there are so many obstacles so it's
like why is it elon musk's fault like
don't hate the player
it's not his fault yeah um but that's
our show
and i really um have enjoyed hearing
your take on on so many things and is
there anything you want to say
all industries are dead no that's
it okay thank you for being here where's
theo is he still with you
he's dead next to me um thank you so
much for being here
everyone make sure to follow bet on
instagram if you want some premium
content also follow theo because he's
just like
constantly putting he's actually putting
his show on there just
just look at him he's stunning he's
stumbling if you're listening as a
podcast you're missing out on literally
the most gorgeous moment between father
and son
he's perfect thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
monday morning show where we deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box all the places
so whenever you listen to a podcast find
out someone who'll sleep a five-star
view about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are i hope you guys didn't turn
this off yet because tomorrow
i'm joined by jackie podcast only
jackie oh podcast only tomorrow i hope
everyone didn't
miss that have a great day you guys
thanks ben for being here thanks theo
for being here we love you so much
you